ابو نائل في بيته المتواضع داخل مخيم
الجلزون للاجئين برام الله يرقب الحاج
الستيني ابو محمد نخله المعتل بعده امراض
مزمنه ما قد يتهدد حياته من تداعيات ازمه
وكاله الغوث الدوليه مع موظفيها المضربين
عن العمل منذ اكثر من اسبوعين يعني هاي
الدواء قدامكم شوفوا انا قديش باخذ كميات
دواء باخذ في اليوم بحدود 13 او 14 حبه
دواء
طيب بخلص
انا عاطل عن العمل والله ما بقدر احشتيه
حاله الحاج ليس افضل من حال نحو مليون
لاجئ يفتقدون خلال هذه الازمه الخدمات
التعليميه والصحيه في اكثر من 19 مخيما
وتجمعا للاجئين في الضفه الغربيه وضواحي
القدس المحتله
نفايات تكدست في شوارع وازقه المخيمات
واكثر من خمسين الف طالب وطالبا توقفت
مسيرتهم التعليميه بينما اقفل ما يزيد عن
اربعين مركزا صحيا ابوابه في وجه المرضى
اتحاد موظفي الاونروا الذي يضم اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه موظف وعامل اعلن
الاضراب عن العمل في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
مع استثناء غزه احتجاجا على مواصفوه بتعنت
ادارتهم في تلبيه حقوقهم الماليه منذ
سنوات وقالت لا تريد ان ترى الا بعين
وكاله الغوث فبالتالي احنا بالنسبه لنا ما
فيش رجوع عن الاستمرار في الا باعطاء
علاوه للضفه الغربيه مع سحب كل الاجراءات
بخصوص اللي هو اعضاء الاتحاد اداره
الاونروا طالبت موظفيها بوقف الاضراب
والتصدي لمخاطر مرحله المقبله تحمل في
طياتها تهديدا خطيرا لاستمراريه عملها في
خدمه اللاجئين بسبب العجز الكبير في
موازنتها
الاونروا 95% من ميزانيتها هي التبرعات
طوعيه وهذا الشيء خطير للغايه يجب التحرك
في اتجاهات متعدده ولكن الاهم انه هذا
العام 2023 يجب ان تكون الاونروا اداره
الاونروا موظفيها واللاجئون الفلسطينيون
في مركب واحد حتى لا تغرق اللون ويخشى
اللاجئون الفلسطينيون في مخيمات الضفه
الغربيه والقدس ان يؤدي استمرار اضراب
موظفي الاونروا وتوقف الخدمات عن نحو
مليون لاجئ الى تفاقم اوضاعهم الم عيشيه
خصوصا في ظل تراجع الدعم الدولي للمنظمه
واستمرار ازمتها الماليه سمير ابو شمالي
الجزيره رام الله فلسطين